[Music]
hey guys it's me jonathan and i'm katie
and i'm kelly and we're here at not
scary farm because we are going to be
decorating a cake while monsters jump
out and scare us why are we doing this i
don't know sounds like a good idea
knottsbury farms executive pastry chef
heather has created a special cake for
us here at tasty we're gonna try and
replicate this cake in three different
scare zones each increasing in scare
intensity and i am here to take them
through those scare zones and at the end
judge them to see how well they did
replicating heather's cake you guys
ready to see it
is it really hard yeah nothing is gonna
scare me neither
i'll go get it okay all right here we go
oh my god
very hard this is a cool cake this is
amazing she did an awesome job are you
ready this
good luck to us heather has definitely
given you a big boost she made you the
flowers she shaped the skull but the
rest of you should we go to the first
scare zone i'm trying to find ways to
delay it but i guess we should just
let's just get in there
the challenge begins here at forsaken
lake a watery grave with horrors and
creatures that have been kept secret
until now beware the gothic creatures
preying on unsuspecting visitors all
right guys here we are at our first
scare zone forsaken lake you have 20
minutes let's go
okay we need to start with the base oh
no one is scaring us buttercream
buttercream i have buttercream yeah okay
yeah yeah is that it yeah yeah yeah no
that's why
i'm sorry i ditched you okay okay okay
okay all right yep yep yep you wanna add
you do that i'm gonna do buttercream you
got it unwrap it
do we have a thing is that a thing
i am so sorry
i am getting an mvp right now because
you have left me here so many times this
is the biggest piping bag i have ever
seen oh my god this is just a crumb coat
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know
let me roll out the fondant you do that
how do you open me
this is the first scare zone and i'm
already in tears how do you open this
the cake is falling apart okay we've got
fondant
oh my god a cake is falling apart there
are lots of crumbs on this crumb coat
okay i feel like they gave us a break
and i appreciate that do you need help
yeah you're trying to pull too much at
once it's not easy they look like we've
never decorated a cake before you have
12 minutes left 12 minutes okay this is
nice and warm can i add this to you yes
add it that's not how you we need to
have a moment of death
then
it really isn't that bad actually the
cake yeah
i know i know it broke man honestly i'm
feeling more judged by the monster i
know they're scaring us and then telling
us how bad we're doing
sir what's up my name is katie yeah we
just need to get this real big they're
going to be like
what about being fair okay okay that's
good all right don't worry about the
back no one ever has to see the bag okay
it's looking better what do we need to
do
we need to take a break
does that stick does that mean oh it's
pretty it definitely doesn't stop should
we just spray with water water
honestly we've just we've gotta keep
going okay we'll do the airbrush spray
it's brightening
all right i got it yep okay great turn
it turn it turn it
we have to go to a whole other scare
zone i'm thinking this actually doesn't
look so bad
i love you someone said they love us or
when you're talking to a monster i don't
like the sprinkles all around the bottom
because yeah let's leave it some stuff
so what's next okay that's the back okay
i think this is good
the time is up next gear zone next scare
zone oh my god
we're fine
in this round katie and jasmine enter
the hollow where witches and creepy
critters have risen from the grave to
terrorize the innocent souls alright
guys we are at the hollows this is the
second scare zone this place is much
scarier than the last place this time
you only have 15 minutes
ready set go we're gonna drink the
fondant over this gold cake which
heather was really nice to make for us
already i think get it really thin what
do you think because it's got to go
around and show all like the divots so
when you drape it over i can start
pressing it okay great i feel like we're
more in our groove here i prepared a
sweat towel you have feet all over you
me yes
[Laughter]
how are you so focused can we just take
your two minute break just give us two
minutes alone time he's looking good
yeah yeah thank you
you're really getting handsy with the
school how much time do we have you have
10 minutes
i broke the tool how did you break the
tools you eyes
okay prepare the peanuts peanuts you
gave it eye shadow and its nose is a
little weird i did what i could
hey these teeth look really good
switch i'll start putting the teeth on
what i like is when we have a knife the
monsters can't come so we should just
only do knife work i feel like we could
just start putting teeth in what do you
think uh one sec i need to do these
little lines okay time to put in the
teeth oh my god he needs braces what the
heck is this it's a cut nut
i need some better cut nuts
five minute warning you didn't cut these
straight enough heather would not like
these cut nuts no
[Music]
houses can you show me what this looks
like
you want to give him a crack and his
skull and i can okay yeah yeah oh
no mama this doesn't really look i think
that is just
you know what i think this is good i
think we did better this time
okay 30 seconds we need to put it on the
cake the wooden sticks he's going on
with our without the stick all right
okay
yeah i'm there
i think it looks good it looks good
all right guys it's assembled
in this final round katie and jasmine
head to the ghost town streets where
hordes of half human half animal
monsters inhabit the fog visibility is
highly limited and the most terrifying
of all the scare zones alright guys we
are in our last scare zone it is called
ghost town streets you guys seem a
little too cozy with those monsters last
time so i've asked them to amp up the
scare factor to really scare you it
sounds horrifying well good luck this
time you only have 10 minutes 10 minutes
i got to get out of here i'm scared
right all right just yes go okay justin
i'm gonna fix this i'm gonna spray paint
these roses i feel like i'm less scared
i hear
the vocals
is this more drippy
i'm just gonna keep going and give it
some bloody stuff here look at my hands
i think i ruined it look at it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is good i'm going to get it out of
its eye you got it in it's all right oh
put a rose in the toilet heather will
like our
artistic interpretation
because honestly his head needs some
help i need some help that's how it
looks in the thing we're not even trying
i don't think i've been breathing
for a few hours
how's that is that looking right oh
you're going that routine i don't know i
was gonna go this way don't swear
what do you think of the cake
what if we just do roses
i'm doing roses all around me
remember when you fell because i do you
pushed me she pushed me i only felt
cause of katie
what about we need some do you just cut
the paper look at that look at that
we're doing pretty good four minutes
we are sisters
okay this is my last flower how do i put
this on is there a plastic on the back
oh yeah it's a sticker
oh man
you ruined my
wire i want to see if i can wipe up that
thingy what thingy the thingy on the
nose the big boogers
this is endless okay wait are we done
we're done we've finished
nobody
can stop us from making dreams come true
okay we're done it's time for judgment
oh my goodness all right ladies it is
time to judge but first
let's recap i feel like the first round
you guys were super scared and i was
afraid you weren't gonna make it through
you kind of had a comeback and scare
zone two and then the third zone because
i amped up the scare i'm surprised you
guys still got it done but those screams
were insane
it is time to judge the cakes i'm very
impressed with what you have done
considering the circumstances my first
thought is you know you don't have the
same height that heather had but that's
okay you still have the same elements i
do think overall it encompasses the
energy and aura of this cake the teeth
are a little jagged i like how you guys
didn't spray paint the roses all red so
it's like a depth of color it's kind of
like tie-dye overall i cannot believe
you guys accomplished this really great
job and thanks so much for having me
thank you so much to heather who made
this beautiful cake good team good team
good team good job guys yes if you guys
liked this video you are going to want
to check out tasty's halloween special
that's going to be hosted by martha
stewart snoop dogg and tasty's very own
alvin don't miss snoop and martha's very
tasty halloween premiering on peacock
bye guys bye
peace
we did good we did good we did good i
really want to scare you guys
[Music]
you